[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur lcp
public sénat émission spéciale largement
consacré à la décision de françois
hollande qui a souhaité ne pas se
représenter à l'élection présidentielle
voilà cette image qui restera dans
l'histoire on en parle avec notre invité
lesquels oui bonjour katia notre invité
pierre laurent secrétaire national du
parti communiste bonjour bonjour vous
avez décidé de rallye jean luc mélenchon
décisions difficiles on en parlera tout
au long de cette émission on parlera
également de l'actualité politique et
parlementaire va d'abord commencer par
cette actualité et celle de françois
hollande
avec cette image qui restera donc dans
l'histoire un communiqué de l'elysée à
19h05 une allocution sobre de dix
minutes et une annonce qui a donc pris
tout le monde de court
marie brémond il tire sa révérence dix
secondes
quelques mots pour une séquence
politique historique j'ai décidé de ne
pas être candidat à l'élection
présidentielle
des sondages au plus bas un désamour
avec les français un éclatement
politique à gauche des circonstances qui
ont conduit françois hollande a renoncé
à une bataille qui semblait quasi perdu
d'avancé
jamais auparavant dans la vème
république un président en exercice
n'avait abdiquer de la sorte pas
françois mitterrand
l'autre président socialiste et ce
malgré la maladie deux septennats au
final pas jacques chirac non plus malgré
la dissolution de l'assemblée nationale
et la cohabitation politique pas nicolas
sarkozy non plus l'adversaire désigné de
françois hollande
malgré l'échec à la présidentielle en
le phénix avait tout de même essayer de
renaître de ses cendres durant la
primaire de la droite
sans succès
la déclaration de ce soir sonne comme un
aveu d'échec pour le chef de l'état et
laisse un boulevard pour les candidats
déclarés à la primaire de la gauche et
les autres pierre laurent est ce que
pour vous cette décision était logique
la compression d'une longue séquence
politique ou est-ce qu'au contraire
c'était inattendu pour vous je crois que
c'est une décision qui marque l'échec
politique de françois hollande françois
hollande n'a jamais voulu pendant le
quinquennat mener une véritable
politique de gauche
il était donc dans l'incapacité de la
rassembler il a d'ailleurs avoué dans
une phrase hier dans sa déclaration en
disant qu'il ne serait plus capable de
rassembler les forces nécessaires
donc c'est un aveu d'échec de ce
quinquennat et maintenant évidemment la
responsabilité qui nous incombe est de
construire un nouveau projet à gauche
qui ne peut pas être le prolongement et
on va y venir voir un petit peu sur
cette réaction autour de françois
hollande
est-ce que selon vous françois hollande
restera dans l'histoire peut-être dans
l'histoire de la vème république qui par
ailleurs à mon avis touche touche à sa
fin parce que ce que marc cette décision
c'est aussi pour moi la crise d'un
système politique ça fait des mois que
tout le monde semble accroché à l'idée
de savoir si un homme seul qui prend sa
décision sol manifestement va ou non se
représenter ce système là est à bout de
souffle
nous devrions depuis un an ne parler que
d'une seule chose c'est le projet quel
est le projet pour la france
quels sont les projets en présence et
nous sommes suspendus à la décision de
telles sommes dotés les victimes de ce
système quand il n'est pas victime parce
qu'il fait partie des responsables
politiques qui l'ont défendu ce système
pendant des années et il y en a encore
beaucoup qui s'accroche à ce système à
droite et à gauche en pensant que la
présidentialisation cette
présidentialisation est un mode de vie
politique normale
moi je pense exactement le contraire
c'est un mode de vie politique
totalement anachronique et d'une
certaine manière ce que nous vivons en
ce moment le montrent il faut passer à
un autre âge de la politique ou les
débats de projet ou la construction de
majorité
prennent le pas sur mes et des badauds
candidature et puisque vous parlez des
hommes il y en a un qui a réagi hier
soir c'est celui que vous soutenez c'est
jean luc mélenchon vous propose de
l'écouter et puis vous réagissez juste
aussi après je ne veux pas faire le
commentaire sur la personne c'est un
énorme aveu d'échec et je crois qu'il
faudrait pas que ça fonctionne comme une
amnistie pour tous ceux qui ont
participé à cet échec bon voilà
maintenant ce qu'ils appellent la
primaire du ps n'est pas une primaire
c'est un congrès parce que vous êtes
totalement d'accord avec jean luc
mélenchon
oui sur l'aveu d'échec je viens de le
dire car nous partageons nous partageons
ce constat là j'étais évidemment sur sur
le fait qu' évidemment le sujet
maintenant ne peut pas être de remplacer
françois hollande par manuel valls qui
aujourd'hui n'est au bout d'une histoire
et la décision de françois hollande le
montre il faut donc à gauche nous
passions à autre chose que nous
construisions un nouveau projet ce qui
était présente
voilà ça veut dire que pour vous
françois hollande manuel valls et la
même chose écoutez ils ont conduit ils
ont conduit ensemble cette politique et
je dirais même que manuel valls a été un
de ceux qui ont poussé le plus le
quinquennat de françois hollande dans
les dérives qui ont conduit à cet échec
politique puisqu'il a été le promoteur
zélés déterminé de cette politique
libérale qui est aujourd'hui rejeté par
les français qui veulent une idole un
vrai projet de gauche qu'est ce que vous
diriez que manuel valls finalement c'est
lui qui est responsable du renoncement
de 300 noms mais je crois que la
destitution
mais non je crois que l'échec de
françois hollande et l'échec des choix
qui l'a conduit qui l'a conduit lui-même
en responsabilité c'est lui qui a nommé
manuel valls
je rappelle quand même que au moment où
il a nommé manuel valls il y avait une
sanction une première sanction
électorale une première alerte
électorale c'était les élections
municipales avec la perte de nombreuses
mairies socialistes et bien au lieu d'en
tirer la conclusion à ce moment là qu'il
fallait donner un coup de barre à gauche
il a choisi l'un verse un coup de barre
à droite avec manuel manuel valls
comme françois hollande ne doivent pas
se présenter à la primaire moi je croise
alors c'est réglé le pouvoir d'interdire
ou ou tel en vain ce segment mais ce que
j'ai fait j'ai dit depuis un an que la
gauche ne pourrait pas se rassembler
autour de françois hollande elle ne
pourra pas se rassembler autour de
manuel valls et l'évidence est-ce que
vous donc il faut une autre construction
politique et je continue de dire qu'elle
doit rassembler jean luc mélenchon et
les communistes les socialistes
critiquent avec cette voix là des
écologistes à la rejoindre et les
citoyens qui veulent cette victoire
c'est la gauche face à la bière le
risque en attendant vous pensez que
françois hollande malgré sa décision
peut continuer à peser d'une manière ou
d'une autre dans la primaire de la
gauche il peut essayer de le faire mais
je pense que manifestement il a il a
tiré
l'ailé toutes les conséquences d'une
situation où précisément il n'était plus
écoutée par la gauche alors la décision
de françois hollande c'est du jamais vu
à cette vème république elle ouvre toute
une période d'incertitudes notamment sur
la question des primaires on voit tout
cela avec eux et la mode à calais c'est
l'équipe d'arnaud montebourg qui est la
première à venir déposé ses parrainages
au siège du parti socialiste rue de
solférino benoît hamon lui aussi à ces
signatures mais il ne les déposera que
la semaine prochaine
le député des yvelines veut faire le
plein dans toutes les catégories
toutes les grandes régions sont
représentées la plupart des départements
sont représentés et en est content et
donc on espère qu'elle aura encore
d'autres là dans les jours à venir marie
noëlle lienemann a aussi un nombre
suffisant de parrainages mais la
sénatrice préfèrent attendre et croit
encore en un rassemblement autour d'un
candidat unique de la gauche
la confusion entretenue par l'exécutif
risque d'être très dissuasif et donc je
fais cet ultime appel à l'unité des
candidatures gérard filoche lui n'a pas
encore recueilli assez de soutien mais
il n'ya pas que le ps qui concourent aux
primaires citoyennes pour le front
démocrate le candidat sera jean luc
bennahmias françois de rugy pour le
parti écologiste pierre larrouturou de
nouvelles donnes aimerait lui aussi y
aller mais sa participation n'est pas
encore actée par le parti socialiste
on verra ce que fera manuel valls mais
si jamais il veut être candidat à cette
primaire qui doit démissionner de son
poste de premier ministre
non rien compatibles rien ne rien
n'oblige à cela en tout cas dont les
institutions rien n'oblige à cela
d'accord pour cette primaire à gauche
aujourd'hui que ce soit ou arnaud
montebourg qui sortent c'est pareil pour
vous non bien sûr que ça n'est pas
pareil il est évident que healy à la
question je viens de le dire face à des
projets extrêmement dont jeu de la
droite et de l'extrême droite qui
s'engouffre d'ailleurs françois fillon
dans toutes les portes qu'à ouverte le
gouvernement actuel il faut construire
un projet qui soit un projet de gauche
et qui rassemble toutes les forces
disponibles pour ça donc moi je crois
que le problème le piège de la de la
primaire n'est lequel est organisée pour
le moment telle qu'elle a été voulu par
françois hollande parce que c'est cela
le paradoxe et même lui ni à fixer la
date qui a imposé cette date de fin
janvier au parti socialiste est une
primaire qui depuis le début est conçue
par la direction du parti socialiste
pour permettre la poursuite de la
politique gouvernementale actuelle si
des candidats socialistes parviennent à
subvertir ce processus pour porter une
autre politique de gauche eh bien il
faudra en tenir compte mais de toute
façon
il avait à ses côtés oui je pense mais
je discute avec toulouse mais le risque
pour une raison très simple écoute et
quel est le problème quel est le
problème
il faut revenir parce que c'est pas une
question cuisine politique c'est qu'il y
à un bain un projet qui vient d'être
présentée par françois fillon qui est un
projet qui cassent l'ensemble de ce
qu'est la france pour moi de la sécurité
sociale de la fonction publique des
services publics un projet extrêmement
dangereux il y à marine le pen qui prône
la même chose tout en se présentant
comme l arme soi-disant opposante
l'assaut vient de se réjouir aux efforts
de l'élection de donald trump donc face
à cela si nous voulons il faut non
seulement un projet mais il faut un art
de force large pour le soutenir et je
pense que c'est ces forces là existent
et qu'elles ne sont pas assez rassembler
je ne cesse de le dire notre appel à
voter jean luc mélenchon dans cette
situation
c' est un levier en iran aller plus loin
et je pense que jean luc mélenchon et
nous mêmes avons des responsabilités
maintenant pour conduire ce travail de
rassemblement et nous allons le faire
évidemment ça va se passer sur un débat
de projet de proposition j'espère qu'on
en dire un mot bien sûr évidemment on va
reparler dans un instant mais écouter
simplement cette interpellation
elle vient d'un député socialiste parce
que il va vous demander de réagir
écoutez c'est olivier faure ce sacrifice
en appelle d'autres
ii y avoir maintenant une réaction de la
part de soi qui sont dans cette
compétition présidentielle pour que nous
arrivions à un candidat unique de la
gauche à l'issue d'une primaire que je
souhaite large candidat unique de la
gauche fait encore possible et écouter
de qui de qui parles olivier force que
olivier faure il ya quelques semaines
disait tout à fait autre chose que ça
mais je le répète je dis ça mais ça
n'est pas la question de savoir si on
est dans la primaire pendant la primaire
ça n'est pas ça le sujet le sujet c'est
sur quel projet on se rassemble bon donc
on voit bien que le projet de manuel
valls qui est le même pour vous je vais
lui que seul jamais ma gueule celui de
françois hollande françois hollande
vient de dire je ne peux pas rassembler
la gauche sur ce projet dont je n'y vais
pas et il faudrait suivre manuel valls
ça n'a aucun sens
le projet de manuel valls et bien sûr
que non nous le combattons depuis nous
nous battons depuis m de bacula les 3000
nouveaux nationale mais pour pouvoir
battre comme vous dites la droite et le
front national
il va falloir que les forces de gauche
aillent au combat avec un projet qui par
exemple disent qu'on arrête avec le cic
eux et non pas qu'on le double com
propose françois fillon donc et qui au
contraire mettre les finances publiques
au service de la création de l'emploi
il va falloir y aller en disant aux
français qu'on arrête de laisser les
banques servir les logiques des marchés
financiers mais qu'on va mettre les
banques au service de l'intérêt général
donc on va où les nationaliser bnp
paribas et la société générale pour
qu'elle voit remettre les banques au
service du développement de l'emploi
c'est sûr ça qu'on va pouvoir rassembler
les français et battre la droite et
l'extrême a en attendant il ya la
primaire de la gauche qui va arriver
sept candidats déclarés 8 si on ajoute
manuel valls comment la gauche tout
simplement peut-elle espérer rassembler
avec un tel éclatement est lent mais moi
je mets moi je suis contre cette
dispersion
oui je n'ai que mes jeudi que le point
rassemblement le point de rassemblement
justement possible
ça n'est pas une question de personnes
ça fait un an que je dis cela c'est une
question c'est une question de projet le
projet que nous portons nous les
communistes nagy serait morte jean luc
mélenchon avec beaucoup de points
communs et des différences que porte
d'autres à gauche
c'est autour de ce débat là que nous
pouvons nous rassembler et c'est pas la
question d'un d'une choix d'un choix si
vous le permettez je vous poserai cette
dernière question concernant les
primaires la gauche voit l'appeler comme
ça
est ce que vous demandez aujourd'hui aux
militants aux adhérents du parti
communiste pro aussi de jean luc
mélenchon de se déplacer pour voter à la
primaire
d'abord la primaire ils goûtent et c'est
incroyable parce que la primaire on sait
toujours pas ce que ça va être
il ya huit jours tout le monde parlait
de cette primaire comme celle où allait
se présenter françois hollande
aujourd'hui il ya plus de françois
hollande dans la primaire on sait qu' à
certains candidats mais vous dites vous
même dans votre reportage qu'on sait
même pas combien il va y en avoir qui la
direction
socialiste qui va d'ailleurs le décider
et puis on ne sait pas alors qui va là
où on se parle que fait manuel valls etc
donc comment est ce que vous voulez que
je réponde à une question pareille alors
qu'on connaît ni le périmètre il projet
ni la règle final caen metz l2 c'est
quand même un petit une petite image de
ce qu ils fassent donc nous nous sommes
énormes et notre décision maintenant
elle est prise nous nous sommes nous
engageons dans la campagne en appelant à
inventer à voter jean luc mélenchon et
en portant nos propositions et autour de
ses propositions vous améliorez vos
adhérents à aller voter ou pas à la
première dame
donc nous nous leur avons donné que nous
allons maintenant engager un débat
populaire nous allons aller voir les
gens sur les marchés au porte à porte
nous allons parler nos propositions et
construire par en bas le rassemblement
autour les agendas pour l'élection
présidentielle et pour les élections
législatives
parce que les deux contes en hiver alors
on va voir justement ce que cette
décision change ou pas pour vous et le
parti communiste kke finalement décidé
de soutenir le candidat de la france
insoumise jean luc mélenchon voyant tout
cela avec un stricte de vilaine pierre
laurent et la majorité des quarante
mille militants du pcf ont décidé de
soutenir la candidature de jean luc
mélenchon contre l'avis des cadres du
parti communiste une campagne qui sera
tout de même mené en toute indépendance
pour nous avons de toute façon décidé et
jean luc mélenchon a pris acte que notre
entrée dans cette campagne nous
laisserait toute liberté de parole et
d'initiatives et donc nous allons
utiliser ces rallyes cette liberté de
parole et d'initiatives pour une
campagne offensive
si les communistes ont soutenu jean luc
mélenchon c'est notamment grâce à son
programme jugé très proches de leurs
aspirations dans ce programme dévoilé
jeudi dans un livre intitulé l'avenir en
commun jean luc mélenchon plaide pour
une sixième république
l'abrogation de la loi elle conneries et
la sortie des traités européens
parmi les mesures sociales la retraite à
60 ans 32 heures de travail hebdomadaire
est une sixième semaine
congés payés jean luc mélenchon propose
également la planification écologique
pour accélérer la transition énergétique
il se positionne aujourd'hui comme le
principal adversaire de françois fils il
propose une synthèse qui était contenu
prévisible peut manifester de ce qu'est
vraiment la droite dans notre pays
je me réjouis du fait que nous allons
pouvoir confronter nos idées car nous
sommes l'exact inverse de cela alors que
le ps n'a pas encore désigné son
candidat jean luc mélenchon espère bien
occuper l'espace à gauche et ce jusqu'en
2017 alors pierre leur en voudrait bien
comprendre votre position vous soutenez
jean luc mélenchon mais ça veut dire
quoi concrètement en toute indépendance
en menant une campagne autonome est ce
que vous pouvez nous décrypter ça veut
dire que nous allons porter nos
propositions nous nous allons publier
dans l'est dans les jours à venir
une brochure qui comportera
l'intégralité de ses propositions que
nous avons adoptée à notre conférence
nationale dans un programme qui
s'appelle la france en commun et nous
versons ses propositions une partie de
ces propositions sont communes à celles
de jean luc mélenchon puisqu'elles sont
issus du travail que nous avions fait
ensemble
déjà en 2012 une partie sont différentes
par exemple
par exemple j'ai vu que jean luc
mélenchon avait des propositions plus
timide que nous en matière
d'augmentation des salaires et donc nous
allons nous allons essayer de convaincre
que nos propositions sont sont utiles
quand la merde ça veut dire abordés oui
mais il y aura la discussion et nous
allons porter ses propositions dans
l'élection présidentielle et nous allons
porter ses propositions dans les
élections législatives parce qu'il faut
bien comprendre une chose c'est bien que
le système actuel enlève tout ça mais
pour gouverner demain
oui puisque c'est l'objectif d'une
élection présidentielle il faut une
majorité et dans cette majorité
il y aura forcément même si jean luc
mélenchon gagne l'élection
présidentielle des forces différentes
mais donc il faut il y aura des des des
forces de la france insoumise
il y aura le parti communiste et il y
aura d'autres forces que nous allons
essayer de gagner et de rassembler avec
nous et donc ses forces auront
effectivement un travail à mener sur le
conte
num de ce projet est donc ce débat là va
être animée il va être publiques
transparent les tant mieux vous avez
commencé à discuter concrètement avec
jean luc mélenchon sur ces sujets là et
notamment celui des lames ou discutent
au new deal
nous discutons depuis depuis des années
avec jean luc mélenchon sur les
questions de programme donc nous savons
ce qui nous est commun nous savons nos
différences j'en ai par exemple sur la
question des salaires sur la question de
l'europe n'abordons pas exactement de la
même manière la question de la
transformation de l'europe et et ces
débats là vont faire partie de la
campagne que nous allons mener et aux
élections législatives
nous porterons avec des avec nos
candidats c'est ses propositions dans
toutes les circonscriptions de france
qu'à leur très sincèrement et la sangle
de voix vous pensez que jean luc
mélenchon peut gagner l'élection
présidentielle
écoutez moi je vais tout faire pour
qu'un candidat de gauche la gagne je ne
vais pas aller en éruption
présidentielle en acceptant le scénario
actuel parce que jusqu'à aujourd'hui
dans tous les scénarios
il n'y a que la droite et l'extrême
droite au second tour je pense que ce
serait une catastrophe pour la france
est ce que j'avais donc je venais jouer
ce scénario là je gagnais rassembler il
il
s'il veut gagner mais s'il veut gagner
il faut que notre rassemblement aille au
delà des forces de la france insoumise
et du parti communiste
il faut donc faire des gestes politiques
pour ça des gestes politiques que moi je
produis déjà depuis des années des
gestes de dialogue et d'appel aux forces
socialistes qui n'est presse ne crois
pas où j'ai vu que dans le nouvel
observateur
ils l'ont c'est une main tendue aux
électeurs socialistes je m'en réjouis
puisque 7
c'est une démarche que je porte depuis
des mois je pense que nous devons
produire davantage de gestes politiques
pour que cette candidature soit le un
point de rassemblement et je pense que
chacun a des responsabilités pour le
permettre
alors voilà on a abordé tout cette page
politique vous propose d'ouvrir une
autre page celle du parlement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et une semaine marquée par ce coup
d'éclat au sénat en pleine séance sur le
budget les députés sénateurs socialistes
ont décidé de quitter l'hémicycle
regardez ce reportage est tout expliquer
par stéphane magnan la scène est plutôt
rare au sénat nous quittant la salle et
nous reviendrons
jeudi le groupe socialiste désertent la
salle en accusant la droite et le centre
de bloquer le vote du budget de 2010 est
nous les retrouvons à la sortie de
l'hémicycle avec leur président didier
guillaume bonjour la droite sénatoriale
a choisi pour des raisons pré électorale
pour des raisons post primaire de ne pas
établir un contre budget ne devait même
pas étudié le budget de la nation or le
premier acte d'un parlementaire c'est
d'étudier et de voter le budget de la
france
les dossiers sont jetés symboliquement
par terre c'est le but est foulée aux
pieds c'est le budget qui est jeté à
terre
c'est un budget qui n'a servi à rien
c'est bien dommage
le groupe socialiste rejette la
responsabilité sur la droite et le
centre qui ont voté en commission une
motion pour rejeter le budget sans
discussion préalable quitter ainsi le
cycle n'est pas bonne méthode n'est pas
la première fois que des coûts de sa
politique peuvent quitter un hémicycle
mais je ne trouve pas ça très positive
ou en institution comme sérieuse et à
des finances de la france exige un
regard à la fois critique et constructif
et je déplore ce genre de méthodes qui
ne fait pas avancer
droite et gauche se renvoient la balle
mais sont d'accord sur un point le sénat
sort affaibli de cette crise
les discussions du budget 2010 est se
poursuivront donc à l'assemblée
nationale qui aura le dernier mot car
alors les des sénateurs socialistes ont
quitté l'hémicycle
pourquoi des communistes n'ont pas suivi
mais dans cette affaire dont ce qui
s'est passé au sénat tout le monde a fui
le débat
la droite a fui lé débat puisque au lieu
de mener le débat budgétaire jusqu'au
bout elle a choisi une question
préalable pour ne pas avoir à
s'expliquer sur ses contre-propositions
parce qu'une chose est de dire dans des
sur des tribunes qu'on va supprimer 500
mille fonctionnaires autre chose est
d'expliquer quand on est dans la
discussion budgétaire où et comment on
va les supprimer
la droite n'a pas voulu affronter ce
débat et je crois que le parti
socialiste a eu tort de réagir de cette
manière parce qu'il fallait justement
aller porter le débat comme nous l'avons
fait nous mêmes et nous étions prêts à
le faire pour justement dénoncé cette
manoeuvre de la droite et je crois que
nous devons mener ce débat parce que
nous sommes sur les questions
essentielles effectivement est-ce qu'on
va continuer à déposer les services
publics comme on le fait le parti
socialiste a supprimé plusieurs dizaines
de milliards de dépenses publiques la
droite propose maintenant 100 milliards
de suppression des dépenses publiques
les conséquences vont être terrible
terrible c'est la fin des services
publics si on laisse faire ça c'est le
foot mener ce débat aux actionnaires
mais également fonctionnaire bashing
bien sûr il ya dans le discours de la
droite
un discours qui est d'ailleurs repris
repris par très souvent par le front
national
à chaque fois qu'il ya une mobilisation
des fonctionnaires mais c'est qu'il est
fonctionnaire c'est les gens qui
travaillent dans les hôpitaux
c'est ce sont tous les professeurs des
écoles les professeurs des collèges et
des lycées
voilà les la wii se sont tous les
services publics locaux dans les
collectivités locales ce qui fait
fonctionner les services publics de
proximité dans les territoires et et et
quand on parle de supprimer non pas
quelques fonctionnaires mais 500 milles
ça veut dire qu'on veut déposer purement
et simplement les services que vous y
croyez est ce que vous pensez vraiment
que cette neige cette annonce là peut
être mise en application mais bien sûr
mais qu'est ce que vous croyez mais vous
vous croyez que france françois fillon
n'a pas l'intention d'aller au bout de
ce projet ultra réactionnaires comme l'a
fait en grande bretagne le trépas
j'espère qu'il y aura des mobilisations
contre ces mesures qui sont des mesures
folle mais en plus françois fillon se
prépare à ce qu'on pourrait appeler ans
est une espèce de coup de force
puisqu'il annonce d'ores et déjà que si
il est élu il gouvernera sans le
parlement par ordonnance
donc c'est pour ça que permettez moi
juste de dire un mot les élections
législatives qu'ont sous-estiment
beaucoup ne parlons que de l'élection
présidentielle sont très importantes et
elles doivent être traitées à égalité
avec les élections présidentielles
quand on a un gouvernement hollande qui
a gouverné avec le 49 3 et maintenant un
gouvernement fillon qui demain prétend
gouverner avec les ordonnances ça veut
dire la négation du parlement donc c'est
que la démocratie est gravement menacée
et les élections législatives doivent
être l'occasion de mettre cette question
politique essentielle au coeur du débat
politique
en attendant va terminer par cette
séquence qui a élu à l'assemblée avec un
débat très houleux sur les vg
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et les députés ont instauré un délit
d'entravé numérique à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse la mesure a été
votée au terme d'une bataille politique
de plus de cinq heures
nathalie gouard qui est contre position
donc été adoptée pendant nos travaux le
texte étendant le délit d' entrave ali
vigier au site internet a finalement été
adoptée après plus de cinq heures de
discussions
l'opposition avait prévenu que ce débat
serait sous haute tension et seulement
quelques minutes après le début de la
séance le ton au sein de l'hémicycle
quand une femme ne veut pas d'une
grossesse lui imposer de garder cette
grossesse est une honte
vous avez déjà bien vu dans votre
parcours des femmes qui ont pris la
décision de faire une ivg
vous croyez qu'elles le font avec
plaisir bien sûr que non et toute
entrave à ce droit oui je m'énerve parce
que ce média en prévention depuis ce que
vous allez raconter comme activité c'est
une guerre de position qui a lieu au
sein de l'hémicycle entre la majorité et
l'opposition
certains à droite estime qu' étendre le
délit d' entrave est une remise en cause
directe de la liberté d'expression le
gouvernement via sa majorité temps ainsi
d'imposer une forme de pensée unique une
forme de vérité d'état sur lies vg en
punissant sévèrement la contradiction en
réprimant la possibilité de fournir des
raisons de ne pas avorter ce texte
flirte dangereusement avec la création
d'un délit d'opinion cela nous ne
pouvons pas le cautionner
et si c'est vrai sur ce sujet ça le sera
sur n'importe quel autre sujet lançon de
la gauche ainsi que de nombreux
centristes approuvent cette proposition
de loi
la majorité des républicains a déjà
annoncé que ce texte ferait l'objet d'un
recours devant le conseil
constitutionnel
alors ce qu'il s'est passé à l'assemblée
c'est une bataille d'une guerre de
positions de bataille idéologique et
qu'est ce qui va se passer au sénat le 7
décembre les sénateurs examinent cette
proposition de loire noon ou nounou nous
la défendrons mais là encore de quoi
parle-t-on il existe le droit à l'image
et qui a été conquis conquis dos à sa
crise âge mais au fond c'est cela dont
il est question
parce qu'on assiste en france et dans
toute l'europe à une montée des
mouvements visant à remettre en cause ce
droit et dans ces conditions je pense
qu'il est important de le protéger et de
ne pas laisser les mouvements qui de
manière souvent scandaleuses et avec des
arguments culpabilisant et rétrograde à
l'égard des femmes tentent de construire
la remise en cause de ce droit et ce
danger existe on voit plusieurs pays
européens qui le qui ils remettent en
cause très directement et en france
quand on voit les propos de mouvements
comme sens commun la manif pour tous qui
soutiennent françois fillon quand on
entend ce candidat à la présidence de la
république dire qu'à titre personnel il
est opposé au droit à l'image et je
pense qu'il y a des raisons de
s'inquiéter
merci tiendront ce sera le mot de la fin
merci à tous très bonne semaine
[Musique]